hi my name is Anna and I wonder is there
any fan reactions that you have been
surprised by like is there a character
that's more popular than they thought or
have people been shocked by something
you didn't think we would be shocked
that I'm reasonably reasonably certain
what people will be shocked by I knew
that the red wedding would provoke a big
reaction and it did I was pretty
confident that you know throwing bad
bran out the window and then killing
that in the first book would would get
reactions and indeed though did all of
those worked exactly the way it did to
the extent that things have surprised me
they tend to be smaller things I guess I
maybe I should not have I don't know how
do i phrase this without getting myself
in terrible trouble I guess I don't
understand women but I was definitely
you know way back when surprised by the
number of women who reacted positively
to characters like Theon and the Hound
as dashing romantic figures the the the
sands and the kind of thing took me by
surprise
I must admit and even more so the women
who and and there are some who really
like feom so that that surprised me
sometimes I get reactions to extremely
minor characters which you know
surprised me uh you know I've had
letters from people who tell me that
Lord Blackwood is their favorite
character he's had like three lines you
know
I think that's what what is known in the
trade is to Boba Fett syndrome you know
you a character who hardly appears but
has something vaguely cool about him
people make him cool and of course Lord
Blackwood has a cloak made of Raven
feathers as his single distinguishing
characteristic but some people think
that's cool enough that he becomes their
favorite character so little things like
that I do tend to surprise me much more
than big things have you do you see
surprising reactions from your a lot
more in it with Westeros um the things
that are being discussed on the boards
and all that stuff mainly it's the
people who who come up with the the
increasingly harebrained theories about
things and people who are very desperate
to pass a time and people who yell get
hype about various topics III I won't
share a litany of strange theories
however therefore the books to resolve
so but there's some really really
strange ones out there